la chapelle de la ville du enc s'offre
une nouvelle jeunesse les travaux de
restauration entamés en février 2011 se
sont achevé au mois de juin dernier le
chantier de plus d'un million d'euros
financé par la communauté
d'agglomération de Saint-Quentin a
permis entre autres de consolider la
charpente de travailler sur la
couverture et de restaurer les fausses
coupes de pierre à l'intérieur du
bâtiment ce sont des décors qui
restituent finalement des faux joints de
pierre que même si on a des éléments en
pierre de taille vous pourrez les
observer notamment sur les voûtes sur ce
qu'on appelle les nervures les croisés
d'ogive les croisés deogiv sont en
pierre de taille elles ont leurs joints
mais traditionnellement on vient
repeindre des joints et pas forcément au
à l'endroit réel de du joint de
construction voilà donc la chapelle fut
construite au sein de la commanderie des
Templiers au 13e siècle l'édifice
religieux a changé plusieurs fois de
fonction au cours de l'histoire à la
Révolution les vitrux sont détruits les
fenêtres occulté la chapelle devient
alors une grange dans les années 60 elle
est rachetée par un promoteur immobilier
qui la revendra à leepa pour en faire un
établissement culturel elle sera rénovée
dans les années 70 par les architectes
de lonet et bonne foi aujourd'hui la
chapelle accueil des manifestations
culturelles d'ailleurs samedi à
l'occasion des Journées du Patrimoine
vous pourrez y découvrir le métier de
vitrailliste